five four three two one
howdy y'all welcome to the second
episode of this genius brain podcast
because I forgot to record the [ __ ]
audio on the first one so we have to
redo it no we got the cobwebs out now
this [ __ ] sucks we can't I don't
catch lightning in a bottle again we
can't we can't it's guys know that this
is gonna be subpar compared to what we
had the first one was so much better
this is so upset it's gonna be garbage
I'm gonna shoot myself at your face turn
this off right now is this trash no
because they were this is so stupid
well everybody today we got a very
special guest we have a doctor in the
house
dr. Ngaba Safari and Ziggy da that's
pretty good okay that's right
[ __ ] you would work here doctor
he a doctor would a tattoo on his arm
you got a tattoo without me you stupid
son of a [ __ ] this will still got these
coasters I got him from when I was in
Ecuador in 2012 to 2014 I was in South
America he loves me guys so this dude
man over sri interestingly enough he was
going through the spiritual hole [ __ ]
and i called you a spiritual help this
boy went off to [ __ ] Ecuador for a
couple of years and you have to realize
when you're in the Peace Corps there's a
certain point where you're just away
from technology and this [ __ ]
just started writing me scripts by hand
one day I got this mail with a bunch of
scroot scratch on with the different
colors right now who the [ __ ] sent email
it was a script that he said me that he
wrote by hand he was a man of very
episode that [ __ ] is so I had that [ __ ]
somewhere why huh I got it someone love
me babe okay I'm gonna read that whole
script at your wedding
getting there didn't you tackled he
gonna be every day I'm gonna read this
script that Gobbo said me
and it starts there's a couple I see you
or my dad grab a microphone
both y'all getting tested I'm gonna have
just like linebackers on payroll
dude what [ __ ] best man speeches are
the worst did you know painful remember
my cousin Jason yeah
so Jason his wedding are my uncle's
super [ __ ] funny not on purpose no
he's a disaster so this dude so jason
married a white girl I guess like she's
white American but I guess I she's more
like she's like ethnically Dutch or so
okay okay she so it's it's a really nice
wedding and half half I say a quarter
the crowds Korean in the other everybody
else is basically white okay and this
full my uncle has a high confidence in
his like high key confidence in his
English but his English is terrible and
this full starts this speech off you
know because the father supposed to be
supposed to give their speeches he goes
my whole life I thought use a game and
my cousin comes up he goes nope and he
grabs the mic away from his head who did
Mike know uh Jason does Oh Jason grabs
the microwave I thought use a gay I was
like bro sit the [ __ ] down man oh my god
but it's the same thing my dad said to
me that's right he thought that we were
gay couple so that you know back in the
day me and David when we first started
being you know mobile
you know you know vehicles I had this
old 1990s Nissan Sentra hooptie hooptie
is an understatement by the way it had
like one like work a headlight
it had like a door that got replaced
because the other one like prolapsed and
then we had to get like a white door and
my dad just got the wrong color red
spray paint just as a Keith will be fine
but spray painted it and that one had
tint on it the other window wouldn't go
down and then it would never go above 65
it had that bad tend to you know that
[ __ ] does like purple oh yeah anyways
anyway so uh it was around junior year
and
and then I told my dad in that morning I
was like hey pops I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna go take my prom date to go dress
shopping after school today and then
he's like and I forgot about it so then
we're hanging out so usually like me and
David like buy egg what would mean in my
house real quick and I'll drop you off
and before I go get my prom date
tomorrow
and then like I go in my house and then
David just chill in the car I'll just
wait here my dad's like he's like who is
that the man you know he's like do you
think that last man he said comes he's a
couple do not tell me give his dad his
[ __ ] African is [ __ ] by the way you
know what the funniest thing about your
dad is too is the fact that your dad
speaks French but his French is really
poor and I had no idea and then I
remember it was when your uncle passed
away and he was supposed to do that
speech and that everybody's laughing and
I don't know why it's cuz it's French is
super bad all the French speakers were
like they're like they're all like
shocked and just like like but your
dad's confidence is up there oh man my
dad he has like the confidence arrival I
don't repeat those names but but but he
has he has a confidence of like a world
leader cuz you're that's supposed to
speak remember the your dad told me the
story about because I forgot what we
were saying but it was something along
the lines of us complaining about school
but that your dad comes sideways with a
story he goes you think that is a
problem I used to walk to school till my
feet bled like yo bro his feet beat yeah
I mean I mean his day I was mad abusive
but then he also like he will like mix
in like truth with like blatant lies
he's like he's like and then I went
through the snow and there was no snow
and then any because he was a refugee so
he's like he was in the Congo damn snow
in the Congo I was like I was like old
enough and I was like I think I was like
eight dozen mmm my dad [ __ ] like
that was the age where you like you lose
like the faith that what they're saying
is true I was like not everything this
man says is truthful yeah that's [ __ ]
funny though either way man there was
this time and by the way we actually had
to reshoot this pod
like I mentioned before I say let them
begin this podcast it already right they
just out bitter party I'm just [ __ ]
partners party of one no because we shot
this [ __ ] I don't get him drunk later
guys don't worry I'm so [ __ ] pissed
man we shot this whole thing and then
it's like I said it's like trying to
catch lightning in a bottle twice the
fact that the lightning onto the bottle
once is already crazy over man it's over
man relationship the Magic's gone yeah
I'm on this podcast man it sucks all of
us [ __ ] oh my god man is it sucks so bad
trying to recreate this [ __ ] the
conversations were so precise I'm so
upset you guys just put something down
the bloopers oh no get [ __ ] about no
goddamn bloopers this [ __ ] was fantastic
before man angry now you just like
thinking like an ex-jock ah man she was
so great I never will get it again move
on y'all remember that one exit I had
though which ones at the buffer so David
David uh named zombie use except they
not you know she lives out here bro what
so so we were at it we had our friend's
house where the friends family house and
we always go there and just for a
wholesome great time because they would
always do like traditional stuff like
the glow ups in Sacramento this place
called Apple Hill chop down a tree
we're from the hood we're like who does
that [ __ ] yeah and then and then they'll
invite us over and then like the moms
like David stop cursing who says curse
it's like cousin you know but then like
at so then one of our friends older
sister like her friend knocked at the
door and then this was Halloween yeah
David is like going to go answer and
then she was dressed up as like a nun it
was a naughty nun and then Dave's like
there's like I know David he's like and
the whole night David was using his gift
for Eagle you just see ones guitars like
yeah let me take some I whipped out my
guitar real quick and I sang my way to
that [ __ ] she but the funny [ __ ] was
this [ __ ] she was so physically strong
I forgot what how the conversation went
down but that [ __ ] just are still
push-ups in the middle of the [ __ ]
Halloween party but that's like for some
reason I saw that
like I want it bro when you broke up
with her she like I don't know what she
thought she could like feel your best
friend she's like she takes my hey who's
this that [ __ ] was on one dude yo let
me tell you this though I never actually
don't think I've ever told this story
but so I'm not going to say her name
I heard she moved here but she was a she
was a hair stylist and I met her through
our friend our mutual friends sister
mm-hm and they were really close friends
now I thought that they were close
friends actually when I found out later
on they actually had a falling-out
because she was a little crazy and I had
no [ __ ] idea cuz she didn't give me a
heads-up right so didn't [ __ ] tell me
that [ __ ] right so you know she's not
started it now mind you before before I
started going out with her I was was
going out with this mood with my very
first girlfriend right and I was super
obsessed with her and so my thing was I
snapped out of it and I was like yo
maybe I should try going for something
different right because I was a polar
opposite it was the exact opposite I was
like I should try dating and this was a
period of my life where I really started
opening up and I started dating anybody
and everybody whoever would say yes I
would I would just go after the person
if they said no [ __ ] and move on so I
really kind of let go of just being
worried about being rejected I just went
for anybody and this girl she sparked my
interest I made her laugh you know we
had great conversation whenever when I
first started off she had great boobs
her titties right but she had a nice ass
oh yeah and then um she was talking was
that nun outfit that really [ __ ] me up
man you you literally stood there for at
least like a minute and a half and I was
like I was like David just I forget how
to breathe yeah and I just started you
know I was like trying to Mack on her
and then eventually we just started
dating and then from dating we decided
to be in a serious relationship now I
did not want to be in a serious
relationship at the time and I knew she
wasn't my type and in my gut I knew she
wasn't the one for me right but she
didn't
pleasant things in bed and so she she
got me this podcast is brought to you by
Skillshare my friends are you an
advocate of lifelong learning because I
am an advocate of lifelong learning I
want to learn at my own pace I don't
want somebody tell me how to learn or
when I should learn but I do know that
after my traditional education there was
a lot of things that I wanted to learn
out there and I didn't really know how
to access this knowledge in a very
concise way well guess what Skillshare
has hundreds of thousands of classes
that you could pick and choose from
because it's all about lifelong learning
there are things that you want to try
out that you didn't do before
and guess what skill sure has that for
you for example for me you guys already
know that I'm in the screenwriting I
have done screenwriting and I've been in
the film that guy in the Sundance but of
course there are things that when it
comes to screenwriting that I don't know
and that's why I'm taking the courses on
Skillshare right now to help me brush up
on those things it's freaking awesome
guys so check it out you can join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free
that's why Skillshare is offering genius
brain listeners two months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
brain again go to Skillshare comm slash
brain to start your two months now that
Skillshare dot-com slash brain so there
was a couple of glimpses where i
realized that she was kind of crazy so
this was the first sign she was a very
combative type of human being and this
was a girl that for whenever you would
we would have confrontation or we would
not agree on something she always took
it to an extreme right she gets super
upset and I wasn't used to people like
this before cuz she was hyper emotional
now mind you she grew up in a very
broken home yeah and I didn't realize at
this age how much it would affect her as
an adult
her parents were a little crazy I think
one of her parents bounced when she was
younger all the other stuff so one time
we were going home and she's she's
Filipino and last time I ever dated a
Filipino girl so we were talking about
this thing called the barrel man now if
you don't know what the barrel man is a
barrel man is like this fertility God
like in Phil
Pina culture where you pull down this
bear on the fat dick pops out hilarious
shoutouts to my boy Rene he's the one
who told me about that [ __ ] it's funny
right it's funny hilarious and so we
were talking about different parts of
our culture stuff and I was like well I
know about the barrel man she goes I
don't know what that is right I was like
you know the barrel man that's like a
huge Filipino thing every [ __ ]
Filipino knows about the the barrel man
and she goes I don't know what that is
and then we were sitting in the car kind
of like a few seconds passed by and then
I asked her I go are you sure you don't
know what is that she looks at me and
she goes I don't know what though IRA
[ __ ] she owned this one she says I
already [ __ ] told you no like that
with the whole neck swivel thing she
cursed at me doing it quiet you're so
dog so I pulled over the car yeah and I
looked at her I said you know what I
would never curse at you yeah like
directly at you so you don't ever speak
to me like that
that [ __ ] was disrespectful that's all I
said right she starts bawling like I
backhanded her in the face like starts
bawling her [ __ ] eyes out yeah
starts crying and I'm like yo [ __ ]
slapped you stuff [ __ ] it stop doing
this [ __ ] it looked like I beat her ass
in the car and so you know people are
walking by and [ __ ] this is this is near
the Elk Grove pond you then you didn't
write no idea she started bawling and
then you know we're at that Elk Grove
pond you that area that we used to kill
yeah yeah so this is like a bunch of
nice white people walking by and they're
just looking at me like like no I didn't
touch her he's gonna help she starts
crying and she goes no just take me home
just take me home
so as we're driving I start driving away
and I'm taking her home and she starts
to laugh like giggle like like starts
laughing to herself just I had a [ __ ]
no we're just you didn't say no this is
out of no and I'm getting a little
creeped out and then when we're getting
close to that to her house and she lived
really close to me yeah
I'm dropping her off she goes you know
what I'm okay let's just enjoy the rest
of our day I'm like nah this is this is
this is this is cool like I think we
should just enter night tonight and then
just drop you off so I dropped her off I
went back home I call the rep was like
eh I shouldn't go I couldn't do it to
her face I'm so scared of her yeah she's
gonna kill me I mean she could do more
push-ups than you at the time I thought
she was [ __ ] strong man
she was really strong you know I was her
only a non-black boyfriend oh really and
she only dated black dudes
also made me show gentleman interest I
think she was deadly interested you she
goes I knew I should stay what black
folk this Korean [ __ ] dumped me
when I got super drunk in Davis and then
I message sir through Facebook oh no I
remember this you didn't tell me this so
you're the one who go go to be on you
stupid [ __ ] where we at the brewery
I said works we were at this we were sub
works then we went back to your house
your apartment because I was living you
because I got kicked out at the time
yeah yeah and I was drunk I forgot what
the [ __ ] happened but you goaded me on
and I messaged her through Facebook and
then she wrote back her back she goes
well look who decided to pop up out of
nowhere
I feel so [ __ ] up because I wrote back
to I go you a [ __ ] my problem yes it
was that's not that wasn't fair yeah but
her she lives in the city now shoutouts
to you girl that's cool man I forgot
about that time when you you lived in my
spot for a little bit right that time I
came I saw you I was working at Costco
at the time I was taking summer school
at UC Davis and then I was working at
Cosco was pushing cars in the weekend
that's right I was going through some
[ __ ] at the time and they was going
through some stuff and I just remember
he's like like he got he's like he was
feeling very grateful when to a man I'll
make some dinner tonight and let me
finish I was like I was like I said I
was a male I go but disrespect sounds
like he's a make some dinner night like
all right that's cool I'll be back later
like I got off at 10:00 and then so
we're getting off late and then there's
like the lot was super messy so I'm
cleaning up and closing out I get home
like it's like probably closer to 11:00
and David I just walk in and I felt like
I instantly felt like I guess I'm wrong
I walking in door David just sitting
there
he's like the food's cold he's like you
can't call your thumbs broke I was like
my bad man got real busy at work is like
we Kudo right he's like nah man he's
like I had to blow out the candle
a delicious light and healthy tilapia
from Costco and I made a delicious rice
pilaf with it to go with it and I just
have some Syria I'm good you know so
what you do is I'll just chop it up with
some people in the parking lot at Costco
I was like so you just had a
conversation with people and you lift my
eye Soviet slaving over a hot stove just
so you could talk to people at Costco
[ __ ] you we were I was closing it wasn't
that long but I had to give that to lap
you to that wonderful stray cat David
would do this thing where there's the
neighbors had a stray orange cat so Ken
and he is also very allergic to cats so
I don't know why he kept like trying to
go this cat to come inside out so I come
out from my room working on my with her
homework and he was playing with his cat
and I'm like and next thing I know I'm
like oh okay I didn't know he was
allergic to time I come back out his
eyes has swollen nearly shut and then
I'm like I mean he's like he's worth it
he's like breathing difficulties he had
like cold water bottles on his eyes oh
my and then the next thing is I aim
anything I can to come with you
I love that cat man my eyes look like
too swollen pussy's like [ __ ] was [ __ ]
up oh I couldn't understand your
behavior dude that was a rough time so
when I when I moved into his apartment I
actually got kicked out of my parents
house at the time and because my dad and
I got into this huge fight I told this
disordered before to but just to keep it
short I got I got kicked out of the
house and then he picked me up and I
lived with him for about a month and
then I lived with gobble for about a
month while he was going to Davis and
from Davis I was driving back and forth
to work at the Men's Wearhouse yeah was
where I was working part time and then
from there on I moved with my cousin so
that was some rough as times man I
remember I had to work like two jobs I
was working at a church I was working at
the Men's Wearhouse and then I had to
work those two jobs just to make ends
meet and pay off my tuition because I
was also going to Sac State but look at
us now
same grab me some sack
the hiad that those were some really
really odd times I just remember Dan
that she seemed like I could kind of
remember that [ __ ] like it was yesterday
to be honest with you but I remember you
had a really uncomfortable futon I was
sleeping on that she [ __ ] up my lower
back right he's got for free yeah so I
got this chair outside and I don't know
if you guys saw my Instagram stories but
I had this neighbor that kept leaving
this chair outside and I kept walking by
it putting up on the story like you know
you keep leaving this free [ __ ] I'm
gonna swipe this [ __ ] [ __ ] as a
joke second day it was still there I was
like yo if this was if this was back in
sack like in South sac area you would
have had this swipe son it's a nice
change
yeah don't be leaving this quality for
no reason right third day I still saw it
now it's in my living room would you
ladies say though oh so the lip so I got
the chair and the barrel comes back she
goes what is this and I'm like it's a
free chair I thought she would be hyped
about it
because it's a free chair but she's what
she says she goes you don't get
furniture in this house without asking
me first
it's my house as well well guess what
the chair is still here [ __ ] and I just
to keep cuz she watched this podcast I
hope not the chair still here and now I
I don't even like that chair that much I
sit on it every day just to prove a
point he petty
Oh I'm petty why I'm straight petty wat
that's my chair that's a free ass good
chair I think we barn on arpaia Bob Oh a
hundred percent yeah amen
like high school was such a trip for us
too we were talking about on the podcast
before this before it didn't get
retorted retorting were taught it we had
educating you know me crying before they
get no authority oh you were taught it
but we had we had a high school reunion
and the high school reunion was so funny
because man it was such an odd
experience for us because number one
when I pictured a high school reunion I
picture that I pictured it like the
stuff that I saw on the movies in the
movies right yeah you see a couple of
people that probably didn't look as
spiffy as they did before there was but
there was other people that would bloom
and look better
yeah but I walked in that place and
everybody looked like [ __ ] I was like
weeba
comparatively speaking right so I went
back and I was like some y'all are very
interesting here because we had a few
friends that still lived in high school
they would talk about high school like
it was the peak of their their lives
which is funny because high school was
not a peak for me at all it was one of
those moments that I wanted to move past
and then just start fresh again I mean
it's the only system where it was almost
like it's like the factory yeah anyways
it's it's basically like we have we have
it's like a mass you know production of
education we don't have anything catered
nothing is catered jessica lee we're all
in the same school we're doing all the
same regimen and then when you get out
of high school you get it choose your
path it just like no freedom we just
like basically mass market school
schooling and yeah unless you're at a
waldorf or some like Montessori or
whatever and your parents were fortunate
enough to get you into one of those
educational systems like you're in the
public education system you just you're
eating whatever they shove down your
throat
yeah so I think like for most people
like creatives like yourself it's not
gonna be a great atmosphere except for
the jokes jokes and the stories the
jokes are the best and the stories are
the best yeah we had such a I had such
an eclectic group of friends when I look
back at it I think the cool thing about
high school or the way that I chose to
navigate through high school I had a lot
of different friends like I didn't
really stick to one group I think I just
generally got along with a lot of people
up to a certain extent cuz I had my
really close friends there and they were
really good people but I also had like
these anime nerd geek friends and then I
also had a bunch of surly certainly a
churlish friends I love it the churlish
one yes no do you remember [ __ ] I
mean I'm pretty sure he's pretty well
now but this guy oh let's not say his
name but because he might watch this
[ __ ] but he was so [ __ ] annoying
what'd he look like
he was a indian cat oh yeah and they're
not anymore but there was one cat that
used to [ __ ] piss me off in high
school you know he not just pissed me
off he would piss everybody off yeah
because he was such a habitual [ __ ]
liar yeah and you know growing up as a
kid
my dad [ __ ] hated lying so much he
would beat my ass consistently is that
why is that why you beat my ass I want
our I beat your ass for lying about the
watermelon slices you stupid son of a
[ __ ] yo first of all we gotta get
people contacts can just jump into the
what so one time when me and David
hanging out early in our relationship
like a gay couple anniversary
I'm anniversary anyways like we're
hanging out David's house we after
school
Eason want some watermelon slices like
some young man would do
I forgot run it some people go home and
smoke tropical fruit yeah so we're just
eating a watermelon and then I must I
left my I peel on his sink counter and I
forgot that was mine or whatever and
he's like me and let you boot damn
whatever like 5-10 minutes later he's
like it's an a is that show a sexual
appeal and I was like it reflexively I
was like nah and I was like and it's
full proceeded to pin my arms now and
just punch me this I literally bit of me
on his arms and I started stocking his
arms until they both were dead that [ __ ]
was so Isis first of all what a minute
boy lying and way I'm glad you found
Muay Thai now he's found an outlet for
his inner rage now I hit people who are
voluntarily wanting to be hit and you
don't stab people anymore either
that's right see I've evolved as a human
being yeah he did stamp some money
elementary school but it was an accident
it was a complete accident and it was
well deserved
so he wasn't fasting yeah he wasn't fast
no that's on you homie yeah we blame it
victims yeah you know me but that was
his dude in high school not gonna say
his name
[ __ ] funny how much of a habitual
liar he was
this podcast is brought to you by purple
my friends can I say something
did you know that a huge chunk of your
life is spent on your back sleeping so
why would you skimp on something that's
so important and vital and takes up a
majority of your living life yo I'm
talking about when I was a kid man I did
not think that having a dope bed was
something that was necessary but as I
got older I started to realize yo I
think I messed up my back by sleeping on
really crappy beds well ever since I had
a purple mattress my life has changed my
friends because purple is awesome number
one probably the most comfortable bed
I've ever slept on in my life there's a
couple of great things that I like about
it number one the the the firmness is
just right it's like firm and and soft
at the same time it's kind of like that
whole porridge situation it's just right
and on top of that because I'm a big
sweaty guy it somehow regulates and
manages temperature really well by
keeping it nice and cool and did you
guys also know the technology behind
purple was developed by rocket
scientists I'm talking about science Sun
does your mattress have science back
behind it probably not purple does my
friends but check it out you're going to
love purple and right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text brain to
eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is a text
brain to eight four eight eight eight
that's B Rai n two eight four - eight
eight eight
he was such a bad liar that his lies
just never made any sense like everybody
would rat him out and our buddy Rene
this [ __ ] would call him out all
the time I remember he did it once and
it was like our English class and he was
he was basically lying about him having
a it was like a what do you call that
[ __ ] a turbo kit in his in his silence
car yeah so mind you I know for a lot of
people out there like Oh a sign it's not
a big deal but when you grow up in a
broke-ass neighborhood somebody getting
a brand-new car is a big [ __ ] deal so
he had this like Scion tC and then he
was talking big [ __ ] saying like yo I
got this I got
[ __ ] turbo [ __ ] you know you just
identified him yeah in the hood
everybody knows whose car zoom in
everybody knows who the [ __ ] that is but
doesn't matter got again but either way
like he would lie about this is this
[ __ ] that he would have a turbo kit
for his [ __ ] Scion and so this dude
Renee that we know he doesn't you you
want to talk you would think I'm crass
Renee is crass and Renee would get tired
of his [ __ ] so much he would call
him out he goes cool well I'm gonna go
over to your house tonight and then
we'll see that kid we'll see let's see
let's hook it up together because we're
nae knew about cars yeah I think those
are not what I meant is that body but
it's not in yet it's like yo bro
[ __ ] stop that [ __ ] and then I
remember when the new Xbox 360 came out
he was like yo I got that new Xbox is
[ __ ] dope as hell and every day
without a [ __ ] beat that was miss he
goes cool nah no I mean I ordered it he
would lie about everything
yeah I don't know why I think high
school was like this big you know it's a
weird place of insecurities in that
those insecurities would manifest in
such weird ways and yeah like you know
for that individual lying for you know
other people to be very quiet I know you
and I we had our own like personalized
securities that we had to get invest but
now like you know I and it and but I do
think those insecurities help kind of
form you yeah and then like how you
choose to react to them make you who you
are today
yeah I don't know why he lied but like I
can't figure out the source I think he
just had like a mental mental problem
we're like he just habitually lied about
it actually carried through college
because we you actually knew people that
knew him in college really and so one of
our friends
he went to Davis oh he did he did oh
yeah yeah cuz I track cuz I transferred
in so I never you never really crossed
paths with him but I tried he yeah he
dorm DUP with one of our buddies he did
and he told me that eventually everybody
that was living in that house together
hated him because he got caught up in
all of his lives he would lie about
everything
yeah and so people originally gravitate
towards him because he has I he's like I
guess he can't be very likable or he's
very likable guy and then after a while
like it's weird when somebody lies about
[ __ ] that
clearly is a lie you know like there's
no way that anybody would believe you
and so you know people were already
skeptical about the stuff that he was
saying but I guess like finally what
happened was like people in that house
just blew up at him and they just
started calling him out on [ __ ] and he
couldn't back any of the stuff up and
eventually he just had to bounce and
then nobody ever talked to him after
that but you know I forgot who I met up
recently oh I met up the guy that lived
with him because he was visiting uh so
he works for the state so I guess he
comes out to LA every now and then and
so we met up and he told me that he's
married now he has like a wife is [ __ ]
oh yeah [ __ ] psycho [ __ ] [ __ ]
marry him
you know I hope you know me dude I wish
the worst upon that [ __ ] I hated
that guy you know something that my when
I was learning psychiatry and like it's
different like kind of personality
disorders and there's like there's
different personality types I think we
all kind of have in our head the idea of
like a narcissist and then we have
people like codependent basically they
were saying like and then the
psychiatrist was she was kind of being a
little facetious but also like a lot of
truth is that in jest yeah so she's like
you know narcissist lex talking about
cells dismiss blah and in the
codependent
you know they definitely need somebody
who's there and strong and all that it's
like you know actually narcissist it
could happen they get along quite well
as a couple and she's like just showing
that everyone for everybody who's broken
there's somebody to complement them and
I was like and I was like oh that's kind
of beautiful you know it's funny as you
say that I actually remember why I cuz a
lot of people you know they fit and they
lie and it doesn't really bother me that
much I remember why I don't like the way
he lies I I don't I didn't like it
because when he would lie about
something he would lie about something
to make him look great and make you look
like you're beneath him yeah I have
better things than you I have nicer
things than you and I called them out on
his [ __ ] once because we were we had
the same history class and then he comes
in and he aces the test right and then
you know the the teacher comes up and he
goes hey you studied really well last
night you got a a he goes oh I didn't
read the book at all and I looked at him
I was like [ __ ] how the [ __ ] you know
about this random stuff at world history
if you never studied it shut the [ __ ] up
I was like yo cuz he what he wanted to
do was say that I don't study and I'm
smarter than everybody else
it's like bro shut the [ __ ] up yeah just
just
claim it yeah I was like yeah I worked
hard and I did well but it was his point
to always lie about things to show that
he was better than people that's that's
the reason why would like the turbo kid
and all that - exactly yeah and you're
saying that a bunch of around people who
don't have a lot of money I think his
parents were decently well off compared
to us yeah so it's like now I think
that's also because we're like from like
the gutter just a lot of good news in
the world yeah but you know I would say
that we're definitely economically
[Music]
under-resourced yeah so and I think your
parents remember your parents are
immigrants my parents are immigrants we
didn't grow up with much but so I think
like any time anyone treats me less than
yeah and I think you have the same
trigger I think that's why we that's why
we've well we vibe you know we just
react with what this would this would
not anger but just like just like
passions like yeah [ __ ] are you better
than me
me [ __ ] you yeah and and i think and i
think that's like what has served me in
school I mean cuz I mean I went there
tradition around with college I went
junior college then I did undergrad that
I didn't med school
after like you know going to Ecuador
yeah a bit of time that's cool and now
I'm like finishing up residency but like
part of like the biggest motivation is
like it's like ah you can't make it
because you blacken you from the other
like yeah I'm gonna be a doctor
watch me [ __ ] and then when your
children are sick I go heal fake shot
you support a Rob Schneider and to a
foreign country they don't get measles
that's not true actually that's what I
would do without a doctor which is why
I'm not a doctor rested that's right dr.
Jekyll mr. Hyde that's me you know this
the entertainment the art I think you
get killing that game I'll do the doctor
side that's right little children why do
you say that and just like stroke your
wood in the booth now we're good
what the [ __ ] will you say yeah but
either way man there was some weird
[ __ ] characters in high school been
there was this part too well I really
want to put this [ __ ] in the script but
you know we said there's on the other
podcast and that was lightweight
regretting that I had mentioned this
story but I'm saying well you're not
gonna bring it up twice yo so back in
the day right so you guys had Instagram
and also the [ __ ] where you guys would
DM each other well we had a [ __ ] called
aim and I'm pretty sure still around
when it's air well instant messenger
everybody had their weird screen names I
was like kimchi panda boy 87 or some
[ __ ] like that but there was this group
of girls that I used to hang out with
hang out with and they call themselves
the innocent eight it was both back is
they got never heard of my life and the
other guy group that we hung out with or
they hung out with them the most they
call themselves the evolution 7 just to
[ __ ] with that it wasn't like some real
[ __ ] but they were saying that the [ __ ]
with them yeah but eventually the
innocent eight broke up and the reason
why they broke up this was like the
dumbest thing I've ever heard of my life
I guess some of the girls were more
close to the other girls and so when
they would go to the mall sometimes they
wouldn't invite some of the other girls
like when they go to the mall and take
those pictures with all the smoke dope
used to give out the their pictures of
that clique like trading I got a couple
myself that I regret and then [ __ ]
what happened was I guess that kind of
like came to a head and they split and
in his eighth became the dumb [ __ ] force
and so they they split into a group of
fours and at this time this drama was
some heated ass [ __ ] because these girls
some of them they were on them on route
to becoming a valedictorians and [ __ ]
yeah water girls yeah one girl her whole
family went to our same high school she
has a big-ass family and she because of
the drama that she had with these girls
didn't get to graduate with honors
because she got into a [ __ ] fight not
sure yeah it was her and her other
friend who recently got married and they
David made a great
so covert names for learning yeah we're
just gonna call their victims Vietnamese
so Vietnam II yeah Vietnam squared came
up and so there was a fight that they
had out to school with this [ __ ]
stomped the [ __ ] out of this other
girl's head
she literally uh sure eighth house
stomped her ass out a stop like I
remember cuz the girl that she beat up
she was I I think the thing that they
didn't like about it was she kind of
pretended to be a really sweet girl but
she wasn't yeah but either way that girl
could not defend herself
cuz this girl Vietnam Square D scar
she's wrong
yo I'm talking about if she was I
guarantee you in a previous life she was
a pit bull
she yeah he [ __ ] was kicking her head
so hard I remember her head just
smacking off the [ __ ] asphalt she she
good she got caught for that she got
suspended for that [ __ ] 9th grade this
was our junior end of our junior year
going on towards summer so there's about
to be summer school I think that's what
had happened it was about to be summer
school so was towards the end of the
year okay and then yeah she stopped the
[ __ ] out of that bitch's head like like
straight Doug style and there was
another instance American History X yeah
there was another instance where this
other girl who wasn't even a part of the
situation I don't know this girl very
well so I was her name in it makes it
easier so Ian comes up and she actually
got expelled from our school because she
kicked our algebra 2 teacher in the
[ __ ] stomach and she was pregnant at
the time
yeah she kicked a pregnant woman in the
stomach and she donkey kicked it too so
he's like the backwards that yeah wow
she kicked the [ __ ] out of her and I
only know about this cuz I wasn't in the
class but I was in the class next next
to it and I heard some [ __ ] going down
so I just got up and I left her headed
to see what was going on someone does
hit a hood school yes a fight you you
get closer you get a little closer to
whatever was happening so what happened
was she was not a part of the drama of
the innocent eight and so but for some
reason she sided with half half of the
group and the one that this girl
actually was the one who got her face
stopped out to
she said she basically says something at
the side of her mouth to one of the
other girls yeah and Ian came up and
backed up the other girl and she started
[ __ ] her up in class and miss
Hitchcock tried to split it up and in
between that she was like if you touch
me again I will [ __ ] you up said that
the Miss Hitchcock then she donkey kicks
her right in her [ __ ] pregnant belly
yeah we're gonna miss Hitchcock if it
wasn't for my sake I mean David wouldn't
be friends
oh for sure man shot ask you for
accepting our ghetto opera project yeah
ghetto awfully what's this we put it
together we went to Lowe's went to
Lowe's oh it was Lowe's it wasn't it was
another one close to your house that's
right
we had to do a board game for our math
class his algebra to honors you know if
anybody thinks we're not smart anyways
what we had to make the son wait to make
tau squares and we didn't wanna buy a
construction paper because we don't had
no monies that's how poor we were
construction papers like a dollar a pack
by the way and so we went up to and got
like the paint swatch samples and we're
like yeah we we need some more tees
Navy's tan and we'd use them as little
squares for our Monopoly board and we
call it get wobbly I'm gonna be on that
[ __ ] too we had like the hood spots it's
like yo it's a corner this is the jail
did one of the most [ __ ] up things
that I ever did so there was this there
was a he was actually Sacramento's
historian for a little bit ooh mr.
Setser
oh this is kind of the opposite of like
the altar thing yeah so mr. Setser
was actually Sacramento's historian for
a little bit but he was also one of our
history teachers I [ __ ] hated this
dude's guts yeah I [ __ ] hated him and
so I don't know what happened but we had
it we had this take-home scantron [ __ ]
yes the test and then I basically what I
wrote on it was like [ __ ] you mr. Setser
mr. such as a [ __ ] so the thing is and
this is so we you get one copy of the
test you take home and you got to return
it so nobody could copy the question is
for the next year's class or whatever
and you go in pair so me and David of
course are like yo you know when you got
a group project we just look at your
friend across the room yeah yeah so I
saw David like yo
and then we in like Coke we're gonna go
eat a watermelon dude be smoking
questions yeah and then now we're over
that laughs and David's like a mass [ __ ]
about mrs. sensor and then he does rice
in the in the column in the margin [ __ ]
you mr. Setser
right and then like I forget though you
have to write your name at the top of
the paper I don't even know if we share
the questions sheet cuz I think you had
your own because it was my question she
wrote it on and I turn turn it back in
and I remember at the end of the day
like that class next day class he's like
hey gobble can I talk to you I was like
what's going on mr. says here cuz I mean
like I'm how's it you know pretty
straightforward the straight-laced who
didn't really get in much trouble and
then he's like hey I'm your test or
something there are some words to me
that weren't that favoring favorable and
I was like I didn't know he was saying
for a second and then I just then
there's this look of realization ah and
my face like oh [ __ ] and then I was like
oh no and it but didn't like the hood of
me like I can't snitch it sounds like I
was like I know what you're talking
about
but I did not write it and then she knew
that I [ __ ] with David and he was like
who wrote it and I was like I can't say
that he's like he's like who wrote it I
was like I don't know he's like but was
it you like it wasn't me
so you say you can't say it or you don't
know I was like I don't I'm just in 10th
grade I don't know all these questions
mrs. a you ain't black so you would
understand well it's like man you know I
had struggles and he eventually dropped
it but I just remember I came with David
I'm like oh you just ass hold me which
kind of I guess balances when I [ __ ]
David and a friend proceedings wait
because that was the moment I was like
he's a really good friend that he will
always have my back but let me tell you
about this [ __ ] story because you
because I would take that [ __ ] back
because I hated mr. Stetson so we have
this wonderful beautiful friend named
probably enough shoutouts to you
probably graduation the second kid I
love baby so probably she essentially
what happened was it was a Sikh wedding
right and at a Sikh wedding they
basically from what I remember she asks
her brothers or people that she's really
closely like male figures in her life
walk down this aisle and then we ballot
the altar or I don't know what it's
called but we bow at the altar in
respect then we going we sit down and so
mind you I'm not see gobbles now see
we're the only two people who are not of
a Sikh religion there and at the the
beginning when we first got up in the
line we made a verbal confirmation
agreement that both of us were not going
to bow because we don't know what it is
we don't know how to do it true so we
went to the front and then I'm first one
up oh wait can i interject no you may
not
can you shut the [ __ ] up all right so I
I went up and I went and I didn't bow
then I walked off right so look people
want to take you away right now that's
assignment because you sir are a crook
and it is it because you will [ __ ]
backstabbing son of a [ __ ] listen
listen I defended you so I go and I'm
not to go sit down I turn around right
and I'm like I didn't bow I'm good
because gobbles not gonna about with me
I turn around this [ __ ] forehead
was on the floor he did a full-on like
ritual bow I was mortified I looked like
the dick that was pissing over the whole
religion I don't know why no okay so the
real the real thing is that we did agree
in the beginning that we weren't going
to bow and then like we just didn't know
how to do it
didn't want to do it wrong then as we're
getting closer I started feeling the
pressure in my heart you know my heavy
my conscious we're such a stupid
son-of-a-bitch you know wait I'm a
doctor I can't say that anyways um so so
I'm like I'm like ding I'm like I'm
gonna bow like this channel mouths do
this thing and then I guess that did not
arrive that audible did not arrive at
David because oh they're not because
what happened so I'm so I've been over
imbalance David oh sure he didn't get
the message
and I just see him walking off and then
he just looked back and just looked at
this look of like just on his knees and
he touched his forehead to the floor he
did the most humble bow I've ever seen
in my life
you you are so close to the floor you
could have ate a crumb off of it you
stupid son of a baby man
graceful no you see we after after this
whole ceremony like come on disrespect
this fool they had to Walker to come out
to walk around this book the holds like
five times and I think I was like five
or six or seven time that they go around
there Mary so I remember like on time
like four and a half my David they bout
to do it I turn around this was all
selling ground
sleeping when did that revolution is
below that make sure worse because not
only because then I woke you up let me
tell you something right now if you
didn't want people to sleep in that
mosque why the [ __ ] is a floor made out
of a tempurpedic mattress because old
people come Nana pray yeah well I know
and I understand there but what would
you expect me to do that [ __ ] was
fantastic it was great it was great I
knocked the [ __ ] yeah you should get
some in hand I'll be nice oh that would
be great dude you stupid ass oh I should
get that movie not so angry because I
because I don't get embarrassed but that
was the most embarrassing moment of my
life dude I was mortified
I'm sorry Do You Know You're not sorry
shut up cuz you did whole life hold on
can can you accept my apology shut up
for you we've got a manniversary
love me so stupid dude we've been
together hold on we've been together
Mona forty because with 14 years since
high school but we were like we linked
up 10th grade so that grades all right
so that's 16 years be as longer than
your current relationship tell Mario
Dow's the original ting Mario you heard
me you heard me treat him right so I
take him back home
this fool says this bull used to date
this what used to date there's one white
girl famous broke up with her right
before a job but it was the same thing
like you did with a grove park like she
start crying to public
you [ __ ] broke up with this girl
before a job interview man no she was
going to hurt her work that it wasn't an
interview Oh so but but I could have
timed that better but you know you got
to make these mistakes when you're young
I didn't date a lot in high school like
you said we weren't we weren't the
coolest guys back in the day and so then
I got like girlfriends in college and
stuff like that and and then it wasn't
working out and I was like let me sit
her down and talk face-to-face
and I was like oh let me talk to her it
into daytime you know it's not I don't
want to go to sleep and think about this
so they're just after her whole workday
I was so shocked that you did a like row
though cuz she was white as [ __ ]
she she was she was as Puritan white as
it gets you know it was uh it was
there's definitely a snow bunny stage do
you got a white audience sorry nobody
stay down they initiated I thought that
was really odd that was I just remember
she had a ripped ass back you know she
uh she was like uh like she was like she
run every morning and I was like how'd
you meet her um we did research together
research and then she did research over
summer - now just remember be on this
podcast okay so I remember uh at at some
point I'm like we're going around asking
questions and I don't know what happened
but sometimes she's she like somebody
asked her a question and she's like oh I
barely wear panties another see you you
are no better than me I was like I was
like no better than working college my
hormones like let's go that was the same
situation when she came up to the front
and she was wearing the naughty nun
outfit and that's all I saw I was like
oh my lord she's like this science girl
just said that in public I was like wow
this question I have some follow-up
questions
funny she knew what she was doing when
she said that comment but she said no
but she said it like in a group like
she's just like like she was kind of
like Santa Cruz like hippy dippy and all
I mean I was like man
I was like I was like I better use like
that Tom's natural deodorant I don't
know why that attracted me at that time
but I don't know I I just transferred to
Davis and then she was one of the few
people on you and it just kind of worked
out like that but that comet stayed in
my mind when I when I of course because
that's the thing that you recollect the
most about her to today's day I'm just
like that's kind of hot we got this
[ __ ] funny story too so there was a
wedding that we went to a while back so
we have a buddy of ours right so when
when I grew up in Sacramento number one
I didn't know the dude was a Mexican for
the longest time I thought he was
Filipino we didn't make sense laughing
was Gonzalez but this dude so [ __ ] up
you want to talk about some backstabber
II would you very much well deserve this
for the [ __ ] that you did to me I don't
give a [ __ ] but so this is so [ __ ]
funny this fool calls me up one day and
he tells me about what happened so we
grew up with this cat since day one and
mind you this guy is the complete polar
opposite of us he's a very very sweet
very nice I'm very well put together
very well-spoken what happened to us but
he told me so when he when Gobbo he went
to Davis after he went to Community
College right and this cat went to Davis
as well but he got caught up with this
church with his church group that he had
I said like it's a cult he got involved
again about the ball with this with his
church group right and so there's this
thing in Davis called picnic day and my
big day it's a big day everybody's
celebrating but usually go with your
homies now Gobbo just transferred over
so he doesn't know that many people so
he was supposed to go with the roommates
I he was one of the roommates right so
so so I'm like Esteban yáñez my first
picnic oh you don't watch this do you
you [ __ ] so he knows he knows he
knows what he did I know that to your
brothers anyways man I love you we're
kuzmin's wedding we've we've moved past
this weaboo passes but at the time I was
like hey man I'm really excited you know
it's my first picnic day like he's like
he's like yeah man me you we're gonna
get
they're like we'll get some food we'll
walk around I'll go to the tables like
I'm not cool like I heard just like
wiener dog races and all sorts of events
like like I've never done this before
you know
and he's like yeah dude it's like I got
you and then we're like cool so we go up
there we see there's like a parade we
watch a parade and then and then I like
I had to like work a table like later in
the afternoon and then so I'm like so
he's around lunchtime I was like oh
let's go I'm like I'm I'm looking around
and I go talk to people I'm going to
work with later like in like three hours
I'm like he's like like it's like hey
I'm still good to start at three hours I
can three hours come by we'll be here I
come back Esteban's with his like church
clique and I was like cooled and they're
all really nice like all doing really
friendly and then I'm just like I was
like oh it's like God well this is so so
so and so and so and so and then he's
like it's like oh yeah they're like
these two are like freshmen here he's
like so hey we're gonna go to the you
know we're gonna go through Dining
Commons with them you know cool right
and it was it wasn't like you're invited
it was like hey we're going but you're
gonna stay here you're staying here and
I was like no I just got like ditched
out for a freshman fresh before off he
was a junior
we were both juniors in college and I
was like yo she just left me for some
freshman women and I was like yo we've
been friends since high school like at
this point we were already like like
five years deep into our friendship I
was like dude it's like this we live
together be we had a plan like this or
straight left is that I was like I was
like I'll just stand there I don't know
nobody I looked around I was like we got
some high school flashbacks with pairing
didn't you know my see this why you
can't have best friends they know I
don't know everybody all sweetspot still
I should never do about high school to
where this dude named ping basically
kicked him out of his friend group you
know but Canyon the pain didn't kick me
out it was his friend oh that's right
his friend mark on his behalf he's like
he's like pain does want to hang out
with you anymore I was like let me talk
the pain we've been friends for like
three years why paying what's up and
he's like yeah he's right oh my god it's
like you little bitch-ass mother like
I'm like you a [ __ ] man [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] it but if it wasn't for that we
wouldn't ever be friends yeah well
paying well now paying you ain't gonna
be on YouTube celebrity about to be the
Rob Schneider I pay reflects that though
okay okay feels really bad about that
[ __ ] no what am i a pang out here is
buried is buried no worries I'm not to
come out like give you know I don't
South man we carry dead we carried him
grudges should we talk about our rapper
friend like that we talk about the
podcast I got wiped
oh man that dude that dude was crazy
it's so interesting because you know
when you told me when you recognized him
at the at the the high school reunion
yeah I couldn't recognize him because of
how large he got he was hella small so
let's listen a specific context let's
give people conduct so the high school
reunion that we alluded to at the very
very very very very beginning of this
podcast
it was our 10-year reunion and then so
you see a lot of people one of the
things that we work on I was commenting
on before is that it's a great little
thing where you have some people who
went the career out and now I work on
that family route like kind of like what
Dave is doing I just got engaged no kids
and then there's other people who like
did a kid thing first like they had kids
like maybe 18 19 whatever and now
they're like you know I'm gonna make a
school I'm you know I really wanted to
like this marketing or whatever and then
we're kind of meeting in the middle of
like of like you know someone's always
working on that other thing and maybe a
20 year we're all kind of at similar
levels but one of the surprising tidbits
was that we saw of old friend that I
went to I was in fifth grade with him
and then now he was this like street
rapper and I think he was like in like
was the LA or like the Florida or
somewhere else cuz someone to south yeah
for a little bit and he's like he's like
Jack he's huge he's super jacked and
he's like and he's and and and and he
said he's kind of like and he's just
like in my Erica like he remembers me so
oh man you know I hear you a doctor now
I was like in med school whatever he's
like it's like oh you know man I've been
out here hustling I'm out I got hella
[ __ ] and I'm like y'all gonna
introduce you to one of my doctor
[ __ ] like yo you got doctor [ __ ]
like I don't know why I was like I was
like repeating what he was saying and
then in there but then the whole time I
was thinking back to in fifth grade he
put a kick me sign on this super sweet
like skinny Indian kid named Opie in our
color from deep and and then the teacher
mr. Setser
the daughter of mr. Setser really yeah
she's super sweet she was so nice the
sign on this kid's back and then she
caught him and then she called this rap
this rapper but in victory for him his
mom and his mom like any like like like
her black mom was like he did what in
school
mmm I raised him better so I don't hold
up I'm coming up there and then she
spanked his ass in the middle of class
and my [ __ ] cried so so so then it's
like now flash forward to like you know
this bum good ass dude 2015 and our
10-year reunion and then this guy's like
yo talking slick out the side of his
mouth dropping money over here and dad's
like you know we can go we should go to
after party I'll get a booth doesn't
that mine I remember him even in high
school he was a small guy yeah he you
thought you had a growth spurt he was
like six four he's like three inches
taller than us oh he's so tall
what the hell happened to him it was
crazy I didn't recognize it cuz you kept
saying his abs like no that's not him
and then and then uh
cailli found his I know his ID yeah I'm
telling you right now I think the cat's
in prison so
you know if we get murdered yo you just
saw me like I love you and I respect you
a lot
yo respect man we just we respect your
humble beginning yeah it was just you
know we just know you from you know from
the beginning beginning you know I mean
the gutter [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah you know
started from a duh yeah started from the
bottom now I'm here I don't know but
then there were some other people too
it's funny when when friends look at you
when they say you know you look like you
haven't changed at all but you can't say
it back to them because I might you look
like a [ __ ] pile of garbage what
happen to your life it's like life took
a [ __ ] beating on your ass there are
some people too like it's true though
after high school a lot of people do
gain weight yeah because we're not as
active as we used to be we have like
sedentary jobs and I think the the thing
that I noticed were people who kind of
lived their peak life in high school
yeah they look the worst well I mean
it's interesting right cuz I think you
and I both had weight issues when we
were like in high school yeah like we're
both like you were bigger than me but
we're Chevy - yeah and I think like it
was something that we constantly worked
on so I think when we got out of high
school something that we still cause
they worked on and we're like conscious
of but I think there's people who were
naturally very fit looking yeah but then
inside they were unhealthy as [ __ ] like
they dig they could like walk three
blocks and they start getting like yeah
yeah but I think it's it's that like
what you don't have you work on yeah
right like if you don't have money you
hustle you you know you don't have
health and fitness or physique you work
on it yeah you don't have natural
intelligent [ __ ] quarry Oh
shoutouts to our friend Korey this guy's
a genius I [ __ ] hate him how how many
nights sorry sorry the site whatever no
sorry this is podcast we used to study
with Korey before a test and we like
we're talking [ __ ] playing Halo being
dumb and then the next day we go in and
we think we're pretty cool with him
could [ __ ] get away with like a C or
something Cory's like it was like all
right like 30 minutes before he's like
flip through thing couple times comes
out with like a - yeah [ __ ] yeah
I think here's like lightweight
photographic memory I mean yeah I mean
but like he was just kind of like so
like he
he's like the real deal of like how the
other guy was always like bragging like
I barely stuff yeah yeah he was the
actual one he was like the real deal
like he's like I you know it's like he's
like oh yeah I barely looked at it
and we know that's true cuz we were with
him the whole night like goofing off
exactly and then he were just like knock
it out which is like goddamn but I think
it's if if you're not naturally gifted
like that you work for [ __ ] like I mean
like I was never naturally gifted but I
think that pushed me to always work
harder and I think that's why I'm here
yeah whatever level of education I got
now yeah and I danced on Tuesdays at
cheetah boys you know it's only caters
to like middle-aged moms you know I mean
and that girl who kicked that teacher in
the stomach also had a big crush on
Corey well I mean cause he was he was
the cutie patootie in high school man I
mean he had he had the brains end he had
the charms and the women after him he
wasn't even trying I know man high
school was such a weird part for me but
now we could spit game better than him
because very sir has he never had to I
know but but we don't do that no more
have you actually seen like this should
happen at a bar with somebody who's
hyper attractive and just have women
come up to them you know who the [ __ ]
that is
that's [ __ ] Khalif Oh Cleve is a
good-looking dude [ __ ] light-skinned
wonder this [ __ ] sent him out
there's some other fish them out like
leave get out you know it's funny
because recently two Khalif went out
from the light-skinned water and so
there was this there was this girl that
used to fall on his crib I'm not used to
I still follow you I still follow cause
she's very beautiful she bad she bad
[ __ ] [ __ ] so I follow her right and
then Khalif follows her right after me
right yeah so [ __ ] annoying mind you
I have a large following yeah I'm not
saying and this girl looks like she
cares about Instagram Fame you would
think she would contact the person with
nearly half a million followers
Khalif not much of a following follows
her instantly he gets a DM from her she
goes hi what's up I'm like son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
look I know I look like a [ __ ]
gremlin well I don't give up look she
literally bm's him like that he goes oh
this go she just DM me I'm like [ __ ] you
Khalif [ __ ] you I maybe that's something
we know
people play by different rules he's just
as scared though oh yeah I love him to
death but [ __ ] him still but yeah you
know I say nothing
this is women just flock oh man I've
seen that sometimes they make me sick of
my stomach I'm just like damn baby hat
working been going through the gym I've
been like trying to get my bank account
right having these gorgeous new locked
up I guess he was that at a bar with a
couple of our friends too yeah and you
know one of our boys he's single so he's
trying to spit game and whatever whatnot
ugly dude but he doesn't look like a
leaf
yeah and he's like trying to spit game
and stuff and you could tell he's like
trying to work his magic
Khalif is apparently just sending there
by himself and then girls start coming
up to a thank you so introspective he's
so thoughtful
if I had his physique and I look like
him I'm all evil with that [ __ ] befool
you got this voice of God did you use
that but then I got a I got a I didn't
use it for evil
you could have he could guys I could
have used it for a longer than I did
I'll tell you what I'll fill him in
because that not everybody with high
school with you yeah David singer our
graduation I think I don't know it feels
like the holiday that's right yeah yeah
yeah but I'm ashamed Louis usually he's
like his and he was he was in band and
his grandma wasn't like closing and she
was like like you had a part where you
were singing by herself and he's like oh
man he's a black and that's all the
black people always [ __ ] with your heavy
back in school you're doing you always
did like David got some soul because
that the weird thing was I never told
anybody in school than my parents on a
black beauty supply store I don't want
people to like hit me up for [ __ ] that's
why yeah because I don't want to know
because all the girls will come up they
would ask for [ __ ] and I don't want that
stuff yeah so you know people didn't
know that I because I kicked it with a
lot of Asian people in school but
outside of school I was at my parents
door so I was king of a lot of black
people yeah which a majority time I
would work I would work at my parents
store a lot so that's like the community
that I really grew up with his I was a
little kid so that's where all that
flavor came from I don't know why you
didn't hook it up though with your
next-door neighbor you had Coco gold
teeth jewelry right next yes you never
hooked
yeah I would had gold teeth at that time
you had those ugly-ass baby brains you
look [ __ ] stupid this tape and it was
a little high a little ridiculous dude
you know you should look [ __ ]
ridiculous that was all bad is fun when
you had the brains in your head that
[ __ ] was hilarious
I got this picture that I might even put
up in this video but I couldn't find
where photos that you so show me this
every story let it be I knew I'd need
some kind of records right now like this
let's just say I didn't I didn't drink
too much back in the day but I skipped
my 21st birthday I didn't dream for my
21st birthday for my 22nd birthday yeah
I went yeah anyways at the end of the
evening David ended up underneath the
shower just like looking like one of
those scenes I somebody who was deadly
dirty it's like that's like I called
next day like they're you you Allah he's
like he's like I was my showers crying
I'm House I cried I was in so much pain
that alcohol boy I started crying in the
shower I threw up so much I popped all
the blood vessels in my eyes so I look
like Darth Maul which I didn't know that
you could pop your blood vessels in your
eyes from putting too much pressure up
there I could have gone blind I know
that [ __ ] they're fragile
yeah I had no [ __ ] clue like like the
anoles driver that's right I remember
because I threw up in a Phaedra's car in
the back of her car she took me home but
I threw up into her little zoomies bag I
[Applause]
started tying it up super nice in the
shoe store right yeah the shoe store oh
they sold my Healy's you had Healy dope
I see my kid with them now he's still
that Healy's right now I was like what I
saw a kid fight off like demon
oh no Healy's Kiku I was like Oh big
black drank a lot that day so if you go
out in Davis I'm not sure if they still
have it but sudden works had this dollar
beer night it was Wednesdays or some
[ __ ] right
yeah they got like they got like five
other breweries out there now but that
was like at that time I was like the
only beer were the only brewery and that
beer sucked to that dollar beer suck
like some works in general was garbage
yeah and I'll stand by that hey this
your beer was so works specifically
you'll be with garbage yeah that [ __ ]
should not taste good but it was a
dollar for a beer and so I just remember
it was my 22nd birthday and I got
[ __ ] smashed super bad I remember I
forgot sub wars also had these areas
where they had private little rooms or
some [ __ ] on the side I remember I got
it I walked over and I got up on a table
and I was like cheering everybody and
[ __ ] standing up on a table like a
[ __ ] coyote ugly girl the hell was I
doing but you know your homies got back
yah yah yah the whole bar cheering for
me and [ __ ] it was it was all been me
they were just talk about this today cuz
we're out getting tacos and we're like
back in the day you'd go to club hey and
now we're just like writing tacos like
like you know the motivation changed
when you get old him you know it was his
club back in the day in Sacramento
called Paul hora por la or that what
would the 18 / Club used to go to like
Empire was gonna know it was rage the
rage the range was that was like 18 else
you said 1800 yeah my bad I mean uh
that's right the rage that was it
Pilate was get up you know man that's
the first time I just seemed like it was
like some asian chick she just like she
was like outside the club it was like
after and that was done and she was it
must be so gone cuz she was like she's
like they're like taking pictures like
whoa and she just like showed her stuff
in the middle sweet awesome I stopped
and I just remember like this I'm so
happy and the guy's like hey man and
he's like I got him he's a boyfriend and
I was like bruh she put it out the [ __ ]
how are we not supposed to look like
these are public titties now it's like
what you want me to do yeah they're the
city's tinny and I'm like I didn't touch
him I'm just I'm just enjoying them is
that the feminine [ __ ] I'm in cities
few t-dog so that club head wasn't a
tourist we're having a bunch of like
Hmong gangbangers there too and I know
this because one of my friends got
caught for stabbing somebody up with the
you know that toenail clipper they just
add the [ __ ] out of somebody
[Laughter]
DB he was a girl but back when he was
single he's loving relationship now
anyways and the girls like on him yeah
and I was like I was like damn girl is
really good and it was and I don't know
like the guy was like he's like yeah get
her Sutton like go dance with him cuz it
asked she was dance like distracted like
he's like yeah you see that girl that
was with like there's I think there's
some guy she was like what happened
it stole my wallet that's [ __ ] [ __ ] yo
he had some bad luck did you tell me
when you went to Rwanda with him he was
dancing and everybody was clowning him
cuz he downs like a white boy yeah they
said I think the word for like a white
person is mozuku in Rwanda and then they
said that to him and then like me me and
my cousin Simon we got super offended
for them cuz you know we just we got
right we got roll with your boys how
dare you say that that [ __ ] might be
true but don't say that [ __ ] you guys
yeah he's kuta he got his own vibe yeah
man that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny man
but that's hilarious that the only
reason a woman would dance with it was a
jacket wallet not even girls were
dancing them but it was like but then
after that I was like man this may not
be the spot for us but I'll be polite is
polite still around
uh nothing sparse in the house but I
mean probably that function still opened
up was a different name yeah probably
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] ghetto oh man I
mean it part of me like I know I'm hood
just cuz like sometimes someone will say
something earlier that sound good it was
[ __ ] I was like I want to go you know
what was nice though I didn't go to
Davis but when I was going into the CRC
at the time you were at Davis we would
go [ __ ] go to the bars and clubs over
there and Davis yeah it'll be nice dude
I have once I was out for my birthday
like I don't know if I tell the story
anyways I was out for my birthday I
forget what birthday was I just came
back from Ecuador as a year I just came
back oh hey no so I so then the hero and
my niece he's like other friends were
like oh let me take him out for his
birthday so we start at this place like
the veers is Irish pub and we go around
and and this is I didn't know until that
day don't go out on your birthday it's
like a big-ass target on your back
so to us I works everyone wants to buy
you things it's
mixed it's a they don't care about
clears this net and it's whiskey's and
tequilas and rums in anyway and beer and
then so like by the time we get to the
second joint
we won't from there once a place called
froggies and there's nobody there I was
like a random Thursday it was like my
actual birthday and then it also kind of
still kind of early so it's like us in
like this couple in the corner and then
like my friend Lucy is like yo let me
get you a [ __ ] shot cuz I got her one
on her birthday yeah yeah and I was like
I was I was like I guess like
reciprocity I got you one she's like and
you got do like you made me do it
no hands [ __ ] and I was like alright so
I go down
girls love doing that [ __ ] when they
drunk by the way they're like calling
people [ __ ] we're sorry yeah I know I
know she said gonna take this [ __ ] but
but I knew God and you have been
manipulated but the South second means I
no [ __ ] no [ __ ] you got me [ __ ] no
[ __ ] - call me a [ __ ] no [ __ ] right
so then I go and then like I take this
shot and I drink it and then like the
the whipped cream tickles the back of my
throat and like my my epiglottis back
there and then and then I spit out and
then all the like whipped cream comes
out
damn man oh my god I'm like I survived
no tokima I look up I see about the
bartender all dressed in black with all
these tiny little weights and he's like
he's like are you [ __ ] kidding me you
like a big white dudes like are you
[ __ ] kidding me and I was like I'm is
cuckoo and I like I reach into my pocket
to give him like a tip and I only had
like I only had a 20 which I was I
didn't give them cuz I hear and I had
like a 100 girls grab it for the one my
friend Nate's like no let's get out of
here I was like y'all disrespect I got
him I was gonna give him a $1.00 to calm
him down
oh and then that's why I don't go
clubbing in Davis anymore this is before
he was a doctor by the way you're in
good hands now yeah yeah I turn over a
new leaf
yeah this was a this was after Ecuador
after Ecuador before med school I was
like it was a little transition I was
like I can't be doing this no more and I
wasn't even drunk it was just like that
wrong it tickled it tickled you throw it
right in the side I say like that I look
at me with those eyes
you so much right now tickles your
throat run sacrum I've got some cute ass
girls though if you guys ever want to go
Sacramento why trying each our secrets
man we just got this game wait oh you
I'm done I'm talking I don't matter to
me anymore I just look like that old
Patrice O'Neal special he's like when
you get old enough like like you
replenish you like your pervert banks
we're just like a look yeah like what he
said he's no you go to Foot Locker and
you're good I'm good for a week I'm good
well you guys that's the podcast man
you know ask any doctor question nah man
I'll ask you about doctor questions next
time you can catch this podcast on
Spotify stitcher and especially iTunes
if you're on iTunes give us that five
star leave who you want to see in this
podcast in the comments below I remember
this podcast is for anybody and
everybody we just have great
conversations and we're just trying to
keep you company I work on your drive
home or when you're doing your workouts
or whatever we're a podcast about
[ __ ]
I'm a good at that you do that after oh
I do it quite often yeah we gonna be on
Spotify we're gonna be on Spotify on
sunday sunday sunday
oh man hey guys those knots meeting you
thanks for everybody who always drops
comments and asked me to be in his
videos don't worry about it I'm gonna
come back when he's doing his movies
that's right and then I'm gonna get
their residuals yeah anyways guys [ __ ]
this guy see y'all next time